the details that i have right now are
very preliminary but i'm urging all your
viewers to provide
any help that they can on this case
police working to identify a child
that's why they are reaching out to the
public so early in this investigation
good afternoon thank you for joining us
at four o'clock on this friday i'm
kirsten joyce
and i'm vanessa murphy christian is off
we begin with that developing story
police say a group of hikers was on a
trail near the road between las vegas
and pahrump
state route 160 also known as blue
diamond near mountain springs
one of them went off the trail and found
the child's body
metro lieutenant ray spencer says the
boy appears to be between
8 and 12 years old police aren't sure
about the child's race yet but he has
black
hair and lieutenant spencer says he
could be white hispanic
or asian he also says the child is
clearly the victim of a homicide
anyone who is who cannot account
for their grandson their need their i'm
sorry their nephew their grandson
or son and does not know their
whereabouts
that fits that description we urge them
to call lvmpd homicide
at 828-3521
so again that number for homicide is
702-828-3521
you can also remain anonymous by calling
crime stoppers at 70238
police are scheduled to provide an
update at 5 30.
we'll stream that press conference live
at 8newsnow.com and we'll have a live
update here at 6.